if you're going to work tomorrow because
that's what you did yesterday
you're not going to be as good tomorrow
as you were yesterday i've never had
anybody
say something like that to me you could
be a great one you could be the national
champion you know some people are about
as committed as a kamikaze pilot on his
39th mission
when i was a boy during the depression
we lived next door to some rich folks
i knew they were rich for two reasons
number one they had to cook number two
the cook
had something to cook where would my
integrity be if i came here
unprepared to make something a
presentation that can make a difference
in your life and when i choose to eat
too much today
i have chosen to weigh too much
tomorrow you see most people never dare
to evaluate
really where they are zeke they tell me
you could sell
anything to anybody i said yeah they
lied to you
so many times you know the employee goes
to the employer and said give me a raise
then i'll start coming to work on time
he was an american author salesman and
motivational speaker he served in the
united states navy during world war ii
from 1943 to 1945. in 1968 he became
vice president and training director of
the automotive
performance company he's zig ziglar and
here's my take on his top 10 rules for
success
when you're asleep ladies and gentlemen
you need
your dreams i'm here to tell you that
when you're
wide awake you also need
your dreams you must have your goals
you'll never make it as a wandering
generality
you must become a meaningful specific
if you're going to work tomorrow because
that's what you did yesterday
you're not going to be as good tomorrow
as you were yesterday because now
you're two days older and no closer to
the goal
which you do not have you can't make it
as a
wandering generality tell us about some
of the
the jobs that you've held over the years
selling and what you've sold and some of
the
the lessons that you learned in selling
over the years well i sold heavy duty
waterless cookware on the
door-to-door demonstration plan and that
was a marvelous experience it took me
uh the first two and a half years i
struggled financially
now that doesn't mean i didn't sell a
lot because i did i sold my furniture
sold my car
and that's fairly close to the truth it
really was then i went to a meeting
and a man named pc merrill who was an
american indian
persuaded me that i could be the number
one salesman in america out of the 7 000
member salesforce
he said you've got everything that it
takes to be a great salesman
if you just believed in yourself and
went to work on a regular schedule
and this is a cookware business that's
right and i put on the demonstration and
door-to-door sales and so forth
i'd never had anybody say something like
that to me you could be a great one you
could be the national champion now i've
always been loved
but nobody ever thought of me as a
champion because of mr merrill's
integrity
and because he had written the training
program and because he had set all of
the records
i took him absolutely at his word
the previous year i had not been in the
top 5
000 out of that say 7 000 member
salesforce
but the year after mr merrill got
through with me i was number two
out of the 7000 had received the best
promotion
that uh that was available in the
company at that time
and the interesting thing about the
success that year
he did not really teach me that much
about sales i'd been in it two and a
half years at that point
but what he did teach me was about who i
was
the picture i had of myself changed
dramatically i
started thinking as a champion and
performing as a champion and i did
finish number two and had that wonderful
promotion
a commitment plays heavily in everything
if you've made a commitment when you hit
the rough spots not if
when you hit the rough spots your
immediate thought is
how can i solve the problem if you've
not made the commitment when you hit the
rough spot whether it's in marriage or
education or career or whatever your
first thought is man how can i get out
of this deal
and so that commitment plays a huge
role and is you know some people are
about as committed as a kamikaze pilot
on his 39th mission i mean they don't
really
uh take it that seriously i was raised
in a little town of yazoo city
mississippi
now i know a lot of folks go around the
country trying to impress people by
claiming to be from yazoo city
but i really am now when i was a boy
during the depression we lived next door
to some rich folks
i knew they were rich for two reasons
number one they had a cook number two
the cook
had something to cook and during the
depression that was a sure sign of
wealth
i was over there for lunch one day as i
tried to be every day
and now don't misunderstand that even
though there was a depression on we
certainly had plenty to eat at my house
i know i had plenty because if they ever
passed my place for seconds they'd
always tell me
no you've had plenty so i know we had
plenty
now the cook brought the biscuits out
and this is not an exaggeration
those biscuits were not as thick as my
wrist was
and i looked at it for a moment i said
what in the world happened to hibiscus
she rared back gave a big old time of
life and said well i'll tell you about
those biscuits she said they
squatted to rice but she said they just
got cooked
in the squat you know anybody that gets
cooked in the squad
you know anybody who's going to do
something just as soon as or they're
half of mine to do such and such thing
you ever have anybody say well you know
what the kids get out of school and then
i'll really get involved in this project
we've got so many things going on right
now weightlifting out of school waitlist
summertime comes and then i'll really
get busy the kids get out of school you
know what they say then
well you know i didn't realize that i
had to take the kids somewhere every day
i had more time with their rescue
waiting to get back in school and then i
really get busy
kids get back until you know what they
say then well you know for the first
time in 19 years dear old centralized
finally got a winning football team and
you got to support their kids there wait
after the football season is over then
i'll really get busy football see you
then you know what they say then well
here it is thanksgiving and christmas
and new year's and people don't want to
be bothered with this sort of thing this
time of year wait after the first of the
year man then i
really get busy after the first year you
know what they say
well it's the weather did you ever see
weather like this in chicago or san
francisco or dallas or wherever
when the weather settles down and then
i'll really get busy
oh i know what you're thinking you're
thinking i've lost interest in it but
that's not the way i do things
let me tell you the way i do things now
here's the way i am see
this is the way i do it
see the way i do things is i get
everything organized i get it lined up
i have everything in just such and such
order and then man once i get it all put
together that's when i really get after
i mean that's just the way i've always
been that way
do things that way i know some of these
other folks are hitting me right now but
you just wait i'll catch them
but this weather it is just so horrible
wait it clears up
and the weather clears up you know what
they say then well here it is
it's easter time and the easter time you
know that's a family time and we always
spend a lot of time together
and you said so yourself the family is
extremely important to you you do the
work for the family and if you can't
spend some time with them you might as
well not do all the work i mean wait
after each is over then i'll really get
busy and then after you see you know
what they say
at long last we've got some beautiful
weather and i haven't hit a golf ball or
wet a hook and i don't know when
man i got to have some r and r i got to
have some rest and relaxation
and you know you said you can't work all
the time i mean an individual
needs some time with themselves wait lie
relax a little bit and man then i'll
really get after it
finally they get after a little bit you
know or when they have the fun and
relaxation then they say well
it's almost time for the kids
to get out of school and that's where we
came
in as we say down home folks you can put
this in your pipe and smoke it because
it's the truth
the people who wait for ain't matilda to
move out or john to get on the day shift
or the new models to come out or the new
mayor to come in
or for the new advertising campaign to
get started the people who wait on the
new senator in washington
or until inflation slows or the rate of
interest come down
the people who wait for changes to take
place out there
before they do the changing in here are
flat
gonna end up getting cooked in the squat
the rule is simple you do it
now you do it now how many of you
feel like i've made this talk before can
i see your hand please
several hundred times i made it
yesterday you know what i did between
yesterday and today
i spent over six hours getting ready for
today
you see i think it would be arrogant if
i thought i could stand up and spit it
out just because i did it yesterday or
hundreds of times
that's arrogance that's when buster
douglas knocks out mike tyson
that's when an expansion team in houston
beats an established nfl team
in dallas i dare not look at the people
here
several thousand i'm taking over an hour
that's several
thousand hours of time where would my
integrity be
if i came here unprepared to make
something a presentation that can make a
difference
in your life there is no way you got to
prepare
for it ladies and gentlemen almost did
not go to the most important sales
meeting i would ever have missed
that's uh that morning i awakened i'd
been up there in charlotte all day long
at a meeting it didn't learn anything
five o'clock the alarm clock goes off
and it was an alarm clock in those days
now it's an opportunity clock
if i can hear that means i've got an
opportunity to get up and go if i can't
hear it that might mean it doesn't got
up and gone well
anyhow uh went off we were living in a
little three-room apartment above a
grocery store five o'clock
weather was horrible uh when the clock
went off you know i looked out and i
said no sane person would ever get a
little crowley automobile without a
heater and weather like this and drive
all the way to charlotte to go to
another meeting so i lay back down
as i lay down the words of my mother
came back to me
uh son if you work for a man you work
for him all the way
you're loyal to him in every way and if
your word is no good you're no good
i had promised this company which had
taken me two months to get the job
that if they would give me the
opportunity i'd be at every sales
meeting i'd be at every training session
and in two and a half years uh despite
my lack of success
i'd been at every sales meeting at every
training session and i'd never even been
late
the words of my mother came back i
rolled out of bed went to the meeting
that's the one that changed my life
how did it change your life it changed
my life because that's the day that mr
merrill persuaded me that i could be the
champion yeah
come full circle oh man it sure did
and uh so it made all the difference in
the world yeah
i want to talk a little bit about goals
on the light of how do you lose
37 pounds and write a book i'm just
going to
kind of give you that as an example for
24 years of my adult life
by choice i weighed well over 200 pounds
i say by choice because you see i have
never
accidentally eaten anything
i mean it's always been deliberate and
when i
choose to eat too much today i have
chosen to weigh too much
tomorrow you can choose to set
goals and realize your potential
or you can choose not to set them now if
you choose not to set them you got to
understand
that the consequences are not going to
be good
down the road for 24 years i was going
to lose that weight
as a matter of fact in 24 years i lost
several thousand pounds of weight
how many of you already know exactly
what i'm talking about but it wasn't
until i wrote it down put a date on
it listed the obstacles i had to
overcome
identified the people the groups
organizations i needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action
set that time limit in there and
identified
all of the benefits to me it was only
when i did that
that the goal became a reality and i
lost
the weight for 10 or 15 years i was
gonna write a book you know anybody
who's going to do just a whole lot of
things folks
i was going to write a book but it
wasn't until i got
busy writing the book and writing the
plans first
before the book ever materialized now if
it sounds like i'm trying to sell you on
heaven goals
how many of you are getting close
already how many of you are being coming
convinced
right quick like that you need to have
those goals there's no question about it
the immortal jcpenney many many years
ago said
give me a stock clerk with a goal
and i'll give you a man who will make
history but give me a man
without a goal and i'll give you
a stock clerk now the interesting thing
is goals do not care who has them let me
give you a classic example
of the way they work in 1950 a war-torn
devastated japan a nation which had lost
an incredibly high percentage
of its young men their cities were in
ruins they had been bombed out
but in 1950 they got together they
meaning
industry and government got together and
set a goal the goal was we're going to
be the number one nation in the world
during the 1950s
in the production of textiles in 1959
ladies and gentlemen
they accomplished that objective in 1960
they set another goal
we're going to be the number one nation
in the world in the production of steel
now when you understand there's no iron
ore in japan of any significance
there's no coal of any significance
there we're going to be the number one
nation in the world in the production of
steel
it seemed like an absurd goal and yet
they reached
their objectives they had taken all of
the steps in 1970
the japanese set another goal they said
during the 70s will be the number one
nation in the world in the production of
automobiles
they missed it folks one year it took
them until 1980.
in 1980 they set another goal and this
time their goal was
we're going to be the number one nation
in the world in the production of
computers and electronics
yes indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely
must have those goals let me share with
you
a true story out of my notebook of life
a number of years ago
got an incredible letter from a
gentleman in toronto with a substantial
check in it
he said my friend steve walker is
following the wrong
role model he's working himself to death
his family is falling apart
uh he's his health is in danger and he's
modeling himself out of his boss and
he trusts you and respects you if you
will give us one hour i will fly him to
dallas
and give you this check wouldn't you
love to have a friend like that
i sent the check back and i said come on
down steve and i had quite a little talk
and in our talk i asked him why he had
such a role model why did
what about this man that made him so
completely
important in his life and he said well
he's the most successful man
i have ever known and i said well steve
what do you call success
now it took several minutes for him to
go down the list
but the interesting thing is though
they're not in the same
otter that i have put them or they we
list them now
these are the eight things that he said
he
really considered to be successful if a
man was happy
and healthy and at least reasonably
prosperous and secure
if he had friends and peace of mind and
good family relationship
and the hope that future is going to be
better he said i'd consider that man as
successful
now i'm going to really encourage you to
take some notes right here and all i
want you to do and you'll be the only
one that'll see it
somewhere right in my as i go down the
list
write whether you get a plus on that one
or a minus on that one
you'll be the only one to see it but it
might be an eye opener you see
most people never dare to evaluate
really
where they are and you got to know where
you are
before you can really determine your
chances of getting what you really want
out of life and so i said to uh steve i
said i understand
that your boss is very important to you
uh you consider him to be successful
when he finally got through with the
identification as i said earlier
these were the eight things that he said
i think that's important for success to
measure success
i said well steve let me ask you now as
far as half is concerned
uh tell me how happy is your boss he
said oh i don't think he's happy at all
i said why not he said well i've never
heard him laugh and he seldom smiles and
besides that he's got ulcers
i said well do i give him a plus or a
minus he said oh you give him a minus
please
grade yourself as we go this is so
important for you
then i said that also tells me something
about his health if he's got those
ulcers do i give him a plus or a minus
he said you give him a minus
i said that also says something uh steve
about his peace of mind
because you don't get ulcers because of
what you eat but what's eating you i
said do we give him a plus or remind us
he said we give him a minus
i said steve i've asked you one question
about what success is what balance is
what's important to you
one question and your boss comes up with
three minuses i said tell me how
prosperous he is
he said man he's got money running out
of his ears and he's getting more every
day
i said we give him a plus on that one
don't we he said we sure do
i said how secure is your boss he said
well he's as secure as money can make
you
and i said well steve let me ask you did
you read where two billionaire brothers
here in dallas went bankrupt i said how
does your boss compare
oh man he doesn't have that kind of
money did you read where our ex-governor
was worth a hundred million dollars at
one point
he's now backed up how does your boss
compare well he doesn't have that kind
of money
now understand steve equated security
with corporate position
and bucks in the bank so i said well
steve let me
ask you would we give your boss a plus
or a minus or just a question mark on
that he said let's be generous and give
him a
question mark i said how many friends
does your boss have i hope you're
marking these for you how many friends
real friends do you
does your boss have he said i don't
think he's got any
i'm not his friend i just haven't
admired the guy tell you the truth he's
somewhat of a jerk
i said okay we give him a minus on that
one
i said tell me about his family and he
said well his wife's divorcing him
well that one's easy to answer i said
how much hope does he have for the
future
he said well before i started talking to
you i thought he had a lot
but right now i don't think he's got any
why did that statement come forth
because for the first time he had
evaluated it
that's what we need to evaluate where we
are are we investing our time properly
using our resources properly what will
the end results
be well then i said do i see when that
was over
we give him the minus there i said steve
of the eight things that you consider
marks of success he gets one two three
four five six minuses he gets
one plus and one question mark
i asked steve a question i'm going to
ask you the same question
steve would you swap places with your
boss right now knowing what you know
he looked at me kind of stunned he
slowly rose to his feet
and said no i wouldn't
would you i never will forget this
particular thing
on the radio interviews i was having
done and did
at least 90 percent of the first 25 of
them would always start with the same
thing
uh zig they tell me you could sell
anything to anybody
i said yeah they lied to you when they
said that
because you've just described a con
artist
no legitimate professional salesperson
would
ever dream of selling anything that he
did not
fervently believe was in the best
interest of the person he was selling to
of all of the qualities that a good
salesperson must have
number one is integrity because
if they don't have that see we are
trained as salespeople to persuade
other people to buy to make decisions
and an unethical salesperson can
persuade people to buy
things that they don't need are
overpriced
or they pressure in them into buying it
a legitimate
integrity driven salesperson will only
sell a product
that will enable him to sell them again
and again
and again a product he would sell to his
mother in other words
that's the kind of salesperson who has
long-term balance success
the unfortunate a lot of people stand in
front of the stove of life and they say
now stove you give me some heat then
i'll put some wood in here that ain't
the way it works
you got to put something in before you
can get anything out
so many times you know the employee goes
to the employer and say give me a raise
then i'll start coming to work on time
all right so many times they will come
to them and say make me the boss
now i know i haven't been here very long
don't really deserve to be the boss but
i just function better
when i am in charge of saying you reward
me now and then i promise you i'll learn
what this business is all about
later on reward me now and i'll produce
later it doesn't work that way
can't you just see a youngster in school
saying teacher if i take a failing grade
home my parents are going to skip me
alive
pass me on this quarter and next time
i'll study more than anybody else reward
me now
i'll produce later it doesn't work that
way can't you just see an old farmer
standing out in the fields in october
and saying lord i know i didn't plant a
thing this year but if you give me a big
crop this year
i'll plant more than anybody next year
it ain't that way folks you gotta put
something in
before you can expect to get anything
out well he's just a pumping away you
know that's hot it's
august i mean uh the question is just
how much pumping
are you gonna do for a drink of water
and finally old bernard said you know
jimmy i don't believe it's any water
down there jimmy said yeah it is bernard
you know in south alabama the wells are
deepened oh we're glad they're deep
because the deeper the well the cooler
the cleaner the sweeter the pure
the better tasting the water and isn't
that true of life isn't it too that if
you could become an
md by six weeks of summer school that
the rewards would be almost
minimal or nothing and how many patients
would you have
isn't it true that if you become a sales
expert in three days of a training
school
that the rate of pay would go down
rather radically
isn't it true that anything worth doing
is worth doing poorly
until you can learn to do it well
we'll never know how many kids have
missed a college scholarship because
they didn't study an average of 10 more
minutes
a day we will never know how we come so
close to promotion
but we grew discouraged and quit too
soon we'll never know
how much more success we would have had
had we just had
a little more pumping in there and pump
and pump and pump and pump
well finally oh bernard just got
discussed he threw up his hand he said
jimmy there's just no water down there
jimmy said don't stop by
don't stop if you stop there water's
going to go all the way back down
and then you're going to have to start
all over
the reality is folks and i'm totally
convinced of this this is the story of
america this is your story this is a
story of success this
is the story of life i believe with all
of my heart that if you were pumped long
enough
and hard enough and enthusiastically
enough that eventually the reward is
going to
follow the effort and then once that
water starts to flow
all you got to do is just keep a little
easy
steady pressure on it and you're going
to get more water than you can
possibly use the basic problem is this
so many times people get involved in
something
and they'll say well i'll give it a try
and if it works out that'll be good and
if it
if it doesn't work out i mean hey ain't
gonna kill myself you know what i mean
by the way
well i gotta tell you something folks
you're gonna pump forever like that
before anything happens when you get
into something grab that sucker
and get with it and then once the water
starts to flow
then ladies and gentlemen that's what
strategist for success is all about
you guys so much for watching i made
this video because alvin
leyden asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur you want me to
profile next
leave it in the comments below and i'll
see what i can do i'd also love to know
which of ziggs top 10 rules
meant the most to you what impact it had
on your life what change you're gonna
make now as a result of watching this
video
i'm really curious to find out leave it
in the comments below and i'll join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon
you need to read at least 20 minutes
every day
now i spend about two hours a day or
more
but you got to understand this is my
business this is my life
this is my profession i got to do it
fortunately i just
absolutely love to do it but 20 minutes
a day
will make a dramatic difference now
obviously i'm talking about reading
something good
powerful positive biographies
autobiographies self-help books
motivational books
books about your business your
profession the industry
of which you are a part books about
human nature how to deal with people
if you are an average reader that's 220
words a minute
if you will just read 20 minutes a day
at the end of the year you will have
read 20
200 page books that is
18 more than the
average american reads in a year's
time that will give you a
colossal advantage in whatever it is
that you're doing
i listened to the people who were
successful in selling that product i
would learn new things from different
ones
new approaches and that's very you must
be a constant student
a lot of people are afraid to try
anything new because they
are afraid that they will be embarrassed
until they get good at it
well one of my favorite sayings is uh
you know the most important thing you
can do is to
understand that anything worth doing is
worth doing poorly
what do you mean by that until you can
learn to do it well
my first few sales calls were pathetic
but i knew it was worth doing so i kept
after it you know
my first few speeches were a disaster
but i believed that i could
develop into that so i kept at it until
i could do it effectively and all skills
are exactly the same way
no running back that sets the records
ever was set a record the first time he
picked up a football
and you can go right down the line with
that so if it's worth doing
and you believe in it go ahead and fail
and the more times you fail the closer
you get into success because you should
be learning on every simple thing that
you do
number of years ago larry majors my
executive assistant
got a phone call from a lady in
birmingham alabama at the end of the
conversation she said zig
she said i believe this woman thinks
she's got an impossible problem but i
believe
you can solve that problem her with her
in just a few minutes if you will
spend that time with her i said well
laurie tell her to meet me backstage
i'll get there about 10 minutes early
my schedule was such that was about all
i had well i got there and i was on
backstage behind the curtain on one side
she spotted me from the other side
and as she walked across the stage i
have never seen as much
anger in a human being in my life as i
saw in her
she almost started crying when she saw
me she said oh i'm just so glad to see
you
i got this horrible job i hate it i hate
everything about it i hate everybody
down there i mean
you talking about negative nails she was
it
she said can you help me now understand
i've only got
about 10 minutes so i looked at her and
one thing i have learned
i don't do counseling but i talk with a
lot of people who do
in psychology psychiatry and the
ministry and they tell me that everybody
who comes to you with a problem
are not necessarily looking for a
solution
i couldn't understand that for a long
time why do they bring you a problem if
they don't want to solve it
well i can tell you why they want to
tell you about it you about it you about
it you about it you about
and if you foul up the deal and solve
the problem they can't tell you again
you again
they want the attention that goes with
the problem and every company just about
it has that kind of an
individual they want the attention that
goes with griping
and and complaining well i looked at the
lady
and it wasn't unkindly but firmly i said
to her yes and you know ma'am i'm afraid
your problem
is about to get worse she said what do
you mean
i said i believe they're going to fire
you
[Music]
she was stunned i couldn't have stunned
him more if i'd hit her in the face with
a bucket of ice water she said fire me
while on earth would they fire me the
inflection in her voice clearly said
they're the bad guys i'm the good guy
why don't they fire them and keep me
have you ever noticed that people who
are the problem
never recognize that they are they're in
complete denial
they think denial is just a river in
egypt
why would they fire me i said ma'am i
don't believe there's a company in
america
big enough to contain this much poison
in one small spot
have you ever noticed that when somebody
is about to lose something they've been
complaining about
whether it's a car a home a mate
a job or whatever when all of a sudden
it appears they're going to lose them it
takes on brand new
value she looked at me and said well
what can i do
i said do you really want to know she
said yes i do that's the reason i came
to see you
i came looking for help but you sure
haven't been any help so far
i said well ma'am i've got an idea and i
will absolutely guarantee you
it positively definitely absolutely will
work if you will just do it she said
i'll try anything within reason i said
okay
when you get home tonight all of your
household tasks are complete
it's bedtime get off in a room right by
yourself
get a sheet of paper out and at the top
of it right i like my job because she
interrupted me she said that'll be easy
i don't like nothing about that job
don't like nothing about those people
down there
and i said well just as a matter of
curiosity you worked there for a
benevolent reasons or do they pay you
for working there she said well i got to
confess they pay me and i said and you
don't like to be paid
oh she said yes i do i said okay tell
you what you do
open your notebook right now we'll start
our list of the things you like about
your job
they pay you for working there and you
do like it don't you said
absolutely but she just stood there i
said no open your notebook now
and we'll get busy on the list he just
stood there
i said ma'am let me let me tell you what
my experience in life has been
i've discovered that in 100 of the cases
no exceptions
people who won't take step number one
never take step number two
you see she had come to me with an
impossible dream
her dream was that nice mr ziegler was
going to solve all of her problems
and she would live happily ever after
well folks i got news for you i can't
solve her problems
i can't solve your problems but i will
give you some steps that i'll
absolutely definitely and positively
will work
for you as it worked eventually
for her i said well ma'am let me tell
you something unless you're
willing to take step number one right
now it's been nice talking with you
she angrily opened her notebook
before we got through there were 22
things she liked about a job
donald not only did they pay her for
working there they paid her above
average
she had three weeks vacation with pay
she had a retirement program
she was in on profit sharing she had
health insurance life insurance and
accident insurance she lived less than
10 minutes from home
she was in on management decisions the
company sent her to three seminars a
year to be paid for
she had her own private office and
parking place 22
things that she liked about her job now
i said man when you get home tonight
everything is finished get off in a room
right by yourself
close the doors change one word from i
like my job to i love my job
get in front of that mirror and folks i
cannot say this strongly enough but i'm
going to try
the eyes are the windows of the soul
look yourself in there and with
excitement and enthusiasm
say i love my job because they pay me
for working there i love my job because
they pay me above average for working
there
i love my job because i have a wonderful
insurance program i love my job before
every one of the statements you would
sleep better
that night you see there's something
hidden in what i'm saying to you now
when she says i like my jobs is really
saying i'm grateful
for my job and of all of the emotions we
can have
according to hands sell you the number
one stress specialist in america the
healthiest of all human emotions
is gratitude i said you go down that
list
i like my job i love my job rather that
is a way of gratitude you'll sleep
better the first night
tomorrow morning when you get up get
back in front of the mirror just before
you go to work
get back in front of the mirror and
repeat the process again with excitement
and enthusiasm i love my job because
and take the list with you because the
reality is
you see you will have started to change
from a fault finder
to a good finder some people do really
find fault like there's a reward for it
they really do
take the list with you and you will be
able to
add to that list absolutely guaranteed
do this every morning and every night
and you will have an astonishing
recovery from this advanced case
of stinking thinking now i didn't say
that to her but i'm saying it to you
that's what it was it was an advanced
case of stinking thinking
well six weeks later i was back in
birmingham alabama
i was doing a follow-up sales seminar
now the lady was not in sales but she
had been listening to my tapes he had
been listening to automobile university
and she had discovered that everybody
sells
everybody who will ever hear this is in
selling
whether you're a school teacher a civil
service worker a military personnel
an executive secretary it doesn't make
any difference what you do
you sell every day of your life
there she was on the at the sale seminar
seated on the front row
grinded so wide she could have eaten a
banana sideways i'm telling you
you're talking about somebody that was
excited she was turned on
i said well how you doing she grinned
even more broadly
and said mr ziegler i'm doing
wonderfully well
and thank you for asking she said you
cannot believe
how much those people down there have
changed
i got a lid on the line folks you're not
going to change anybody else
did you change you everything really
does begin
with you now you see the unfortunate
thing this lady had been raised in a
very negative environment
first their parents have told it they
should never amount to anything
they said you know you're always late
you're always sloppy why can't you be
like your brother or your sister
or whatever when she got married her
husband had continued it
and so her self-talk had become
completely negative everything that she
said about herself was negative
you know like dad said i'll never amount
to anything or like my husband says i
can't do
anything right but when she started
changing the input then some radical
changes took place